All right, kids, here's Grandpa's book, A Village Noad for Vegetables.
It a village noad for vegetables on an island off the coast.
The people grew tomatoes large, so large that they would boast and cucumbers, green and
narrow. They were sold across the sea, melons, beets and berries, peppers hot and broccoli.
Ignatio Pumper Schnitzel Pentalgrass led the people of the town. For he was the mayor
of Hangleberg, the best man for the job they found. He watched the growers of the vines
and guarded secrets of the soil. That made the village Hangleberg, the Maylands, most desired
spoil. For every day at due time ships would sail across the Ford and bed would buy the
vegetables till there was no raw room on board. The people on the Mayland raved at Hangleberg's
lights. How could one small island grow such food so pure and bright?
Ignatio Pumper Schnitzel smiled, the proudest man I know. He'd greet the Maylands bare
derand with, ah, you're welcome to all we grow. As time passed, the Mayland people rose and
cried in selfish rage. We're tired of sailing to the aisle for lettuce, squash and sage.
They at bare derand demanded, more and more and more. Ignatio Pumper Schnitzel Pentalgrass said
they could just come ashore. For all we have is yours, the villagers agreed. Come fill your
sacks with peppers, nuts and carrots for your families. Contentment was a virtue. Mayland
people knew not of. For as for they simply grew more selfish and much more void of love.
They soon captured poor Ignatio for a ransom for their loot and demanded every vegetable,
every plate that bore a fruit. They brought shovels, picks and axes.
They gathered every living thing. They put them in their ships and took them to the
Mayland in the spring. Ignatio cried, what ours is yours. We have always shared our lot.
You may take all of our possessions but the secret we've still got.
Mayor derand and Mayland people laughed and said, no we have it all. We don't need your
island village or your harvests in the fall. So they dumped poor Ignatio Pentalgrass back on the
barren soil and sailed on home and burned the boats to protect their new found spoil.
While the Mayland people took the greens they stole into the market place and sold them to the bitter
high as for a trophy case. But since each one knew nothing of the plants and how they grow as summer
came they withered, wilted, sadly bowing low. Not a one produced a fruit, most had browned and
died before it flowered. The Mayland people was proud warriors, now just hungry cowards.
What always thought for loss before the cold winds began to blow, the Mayland people
knew their heir would bring much sorrow with the snow. But in the distant was a ship that Mayor
derand could see as he gazed through the looking glass. It's coming closer was his plea.
The people grabbed their weapons, sticks and clubs for to defend but as the ship approached they
heard we want to be your friend. To their amazement it was Ignatio. We would have come much
sooner was his cry but we had to build this boat and we were waiting for the rye. Then they spilled out
on the dock wheat and cherries, salary, kale, onions, chard and radishes and berries by the pale.
The Mayland people wept and they fell upon their face. We don't deserve such blessings from the ones
we did disgrace. But poor Ignatio, petal grass of Hagelberg the Isle, said it's time to tell the secret.
So he sat for just a while. Our mercy for the Mayland simply mirrors mercy found
through another long ago, similarly so unfairly bound. We gave all we had to you because he did just
the same but in this simple truth lies the secret for which we came all we have and all we give
is not because of our great land. We gave ourselves to him and now he blesses the work of our hands.
The people of the Mayland, with their now repented mayor sobbed before Ignatio as he led them
then in prayer. While time has passed and Mayland people learned that life is a privilege
and to keep in touch with Hagelberg now they built a two-lane bridge.